I want this this this this this cool  then you're gonna have to accept it  ain't gonna be loyal to you he's barely  going to reply to you that's the game  I don't I swear to God no because all  you'll ever talk about is your exes that  cheated on you that's all you'll ever  talk about and it's like it's like I  always talks about that the regular  women that are running the women that  come on good thing I'm irregular and  extraordinaire but do you not think it's  because we're not holding men  accountable so when I'm mad because he's  a top J cheats on a woman it's like well  what do you expect when you should  actually turn around for what  accountable person okay accountable for  its natural evolutionary biology it's  cheating morally correct yes it depends  yes  how can you say that are you okay with  your woman cheating on you then  absolutely no because oh it's a rap when  she cheats on you but you can cheat on